من امام المنزل الذي تم استهدافه اليوم في
نابلس تنضم الينا مراسه الجزيره جيفارا
جيفارا
تفاصيل عمليه استهداف
الفلسطينيه 3 في هذا المنزل وماذا عن
الاجواء بعد تشييعهم
[موسيقى]
بالطبع اجواء من الغضب الشديد وعيد من قبل
فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه خلال جنازه
التشييع بالردوه مواصله المقاومه الجنازه
هذا اليوم كانت استثنائيه بمعنى ان
الرايات لكل الفصائل الفلسطينيه كانت
مرفوعه للتاكيد على وحده الحال وحده
المقاومين الفلسطينيين في الميدان
وبالتالي ذلك ايضا رساله من قبل المقاومين
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي نحن بالطبع كما ذكرتي
في يعني في محيط المنزل الذي تم استهدافه
ما حدث اليوم ان وحدات من المستعربين
كانوا يلبسون وفق بعض الفيديوهات التي تم
التقاطها من كاميرات للمحال والمنازل
وقفوا عند هذه المنطقه تحديدا لمراقبه
الموقع ولكن كان هناك مسيره خلال الايام
الماضيه تحوم في هذه المنطقه
دخل اعضائها بلباس نساء بلباس رجال عمال
نظافه وغيرها
وعندما تم كشف امرهم بدات الاشتباكات
المسلحه مع مقاومين فلسطينيين ولكن بالطبع
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ككل عمليه يكون
هناك عشرات الاليات العسكريه التي تقتحم
على الفور المنطقه تم محاصره المنزل ان
استطعنا ان نرى والان الزميل رمضان يرينا
هنا ما يحدث حجم الدمار الهائل الذي احدث
في هذه الغرفه لا نتحدث عن منزل نتحدث عن
غرفه في داخل هذه الغرفه تحديدا في الداخل
من هناك نحن لن نتمكن من النزول لان الان
هذه
يعني ثلاثه طوابق يمكن ان تكون ايله
للسقوط في ايه لحظه بالطبع القوات او
الوحدات المختصه الفلسطينيه قامت باغلاق
المنطقه بالكامل بعد استخراج الجثامين
لفحص الامكان هناك متفجرات في داخل المنزل
خاصه اننا نرى حجم الدماء الموجوده حتى
يعني ان استطعنا ان نرى عبر هذه هذا
الفراش او اللوح الخشبي حجم الدماء
وفق شهود العيان هنا فعلى الاقل الوحدات
الخاصه التي اقتحمت وحاصرت المنزل استخدمت
ثلاثه صواريخ انيرجا تم اطلاق النار من
مواقع عده تحيط بهذه الغرفه دمار كبير
ولكن وفق ايضا شهود العيان والعائلات التي
تحيط بالمنزل اكدوا انه كما راينا من
المنزل من اليمين الان من اليسار هذه
العائلات حوصرت حاصرتها القوات الخاصه في
داخل غرف وقامت ايضا باطلاق النار من هذه
الشرفه اذا تم اطلاق النار من كافه
المواقع
ذلك على ثلاثه شبان وفق مزاعم الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تم العثور على
اسلحه ناريه كلاشنكوف وام سته عشر
وان بالطبع هذه
الوحده حسب وصف الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اي
الشبان الثلاثه يتهمون بتنفيذ عمليه
الحمراء في الاغوار في شهر رمضان المبارك
كتائب عز الدين القسام الذراع المسرح
لحركه حماس اكدت ونعت الشهداء الثلاثه
اكدت انها انهم من كوادرها وان هذه
العمليه جاءت على الفور بعد تدنيس المسجد
الاقصى المبارك في شهر رمضان المبارك
الاعتداء على المعتكفات تحديدا وان
العمليات ستتواصل يعني ساشير لك فقط هنا
فدا ان تستطيعون ان تروا معنا يعني ليس
فقط صواريخ ليس فقط
اسلحه من اشكال يعني حتى نستطيع هذا عدد
قليل جدا من الرصاص او ما تبقى من رصاص من
فوهات البنادق التي اطلقها جنود الاحتلال
موجوده الان مع الاهالي
تفقدونها نهار نابلس لم يكن قد انتهى بعد
انسحاب قوات الاحتلال
وانتهاء تشييع الشهداء في هذه اللحظه
بالذات ايضا قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
قامت
حسب الوصف الفلسطيني باعدام الشابه ايمان
عوده في بلده حواره جنوب نابلس بزعم انها
حاولت طعن احد الجنود وانه اصيب بجراح
طفيفه في الكتف بينما الفلسطينيون يفندون
هذه الروايه ويقولون كيف يمكن لامراه لا
تحمل الا سكين صغير ان تقترب من موقع فيه
عشرات الجنود المدججين بالاسلحه يعني نحن
في حواره منذ اشهر عديده وكنا نرى معكم
كيف التواجد العسكري المكثف في قوات
الاحتلال في تلك المنطقه ولكن ايضا وفق
مراقبين البعض يرى ان هذا الحجم من الدمار
الموجود وهذا التحطيم
وقطعه الكهرباء عن كل هذه المنطقه خلال
ساعات العمليه هو رساله لكل من ينتقد
نتنياهو شخصيا والائتلاف الحكومي خاصه
بعدما حدث مع غزه عقب استشهاد الاسير
المضرب عن الطعام خضر عدنان وبالتالي ايضا
لمحاوله الرد على المنتقدين نتنياهو في
للقضايا الاصلاحيه وان الدم الفلسطيني هو
الضريبه جيفارا البديري شكرا لك